I think redesign in the world has to
Center on managing the really big
challenge of the next century which is
the range of levels of interdependence
and that's going to require cooperation
of a kind that we have not seen before
cooperation among countries among
organizations and among individuals and
I think the real challenge is how do we
structure those lines of cooperation to
ensure that we can address the
challenges that are inescapably global
of course that's national security it's
the interdependence of our economies
it's also problems by climate change
that are absolutely and completely
requiring a global cooperation and I
think the real question is what is the
institutional structure and right now we
have a very thin veneer of cooperation
with some institutions that are working
but others that are really quite
dysfunctional and I think in the area
that I work on most the environment
we're in real need of a global global
overhaul a complete refinement and
reform and the creating of a robust
global environmental organization